[Music]
it's been as always a dramatic season of
bachelor in paradise
et spoke with the cast at their reunion
taping where the phrase boy was used
quite a lot
who was the biggest play this season
well you know I think I mean Dean would
be up there I can have like the most
amazing girl in the entire world in
front of me and yet here I am flirting
with another girl in the pool yeah I
mean there were a lot of boys that
season it was bad I hope next season's
better but who was the biggest one gosh
I have to say Dean the empties behavior
on Paradise heard his chances of
becoming a bachelor I would say so you
know maybe not in the future but for
this season I think he proved that he's
definitely not ready to date anybody and
let alone multiple girls I don't think
he handled dating to very well so I
can't imagine how he did 25 was this
season the season of boys this season
was probably they're probably a lot more
boys in the season he's the biggest one
ooh if I gotta go big as boy biggest
perceived boy Dean hundred percent hands
down I don't think it without him we
probably don't have the work way in the
season was this the season of boys yes
it was who is the biggest island
[Music]
you